you know movies can teach us a lot about
life what I learned from this movie is
when the cops are bogged down and they
can't do their job because of the red
tape just get a 911 dispatcher with a
lot of time on our hands a lot of weight
on our shoulders and a movie with a
shitty third act she might be able to
crack the case
the call spoiler alert I hate the end of
this movie so in the call Halle Berry
plays a 911 at the very beginning of the
movie more or less she was responsible
for our girls debt now Halle Berry's
racked with guilt while those dead girls
hanging out with Halle Berry's alias
status so now someone kidnapped abigail
breslin and now abigail breslin dials
9-1-1 and Halle Berry has to take that
call so now she feels like if she saves
this girl's life she will find
redemption probably won't get her a low
status back but she'll find redemption
so the movie's more or less revolves
around abigail breslin in the trunk of
this car talking with Halle Berry and
Halle Berry is trying to talk her
through ways to get the signal out you
know punch out the taillights waiver
arms it's more or less the cops are
trying to find where this girl is they
can't trace the cell phone so it's her
and Halle Berry talking on the phone
like BFF should and if this movie sounds
like the 99-cent grade-b version of a
really good kidnapping movie well that's
because it more or less is there's one
of those movies I'm watching and I'm
like alright yeah kidnapping movie it is
interesting as it is to see Halle Berry
talking with this girl there's girl
talking with Halle Berry and the two
were going back and forth fact is
nothing stands out in this movie I mean
Halle Berry's in the movie which would
have been really cool like ten years ago
not like it's like oh it's a Halle Berry
movie I have to see this movie now
because Halle Berry's in it she did find
in the movie but anyone could have
played her Astrid from fringe could have
played this role and let's face it
that's who was supposed to do it it's
just observation you know it's true I
mean the guy who kidnapped her is this
total crazy Norman Bates type guy and
he's supposed to be and you have a crazy
guy being crazy it's because he's crazy
who this guy is I have no idea he looks
like the love child of Peter Berg and
Eddie burns actually yeah so among the
police chase and a girl being in the
trunk of a car which is pretty much most
of this movie in the end the cops are
looking for and Halle Berry's like hmm
I'm gonna take matters into my own hands
which I was like why don't you just call
911 you have a hunch you're pretty
by-the-book so call 911 success I know
of Halle Berry has to take matters into
her own hands and then we have the last
act of this movie which is pretty much
the Halle Berry show and her being one
chick army of not cop then it's all
cliched [ __ ] and then the movie ends
what I hate about the ending and I'm not
going to spoil it right here I will tell
you more about the ending later in this
review and I'll have the whole spoiler
alert' thing right there so you guys
know it's a spoiler but I hate it
because it's like one of those hey we're
gonna turn the tables but I just
wouldn't work logically it would not
work not only is it out of character for
Halle Berry to do this because
she is like I said a by-the-book kind of
person but it just legally wouldn't work
in the end it was an interesting premise
on paper it's not uninteresting as
you're watching it when the movie is
almost done you're like it is
forgettable is entertaining while I'm
watching it but it's forgettable in the
last act of the movie happens you're
like I'm never gonna suggest this movie
to anyone I will say the movies not
great and you're not gonna remember in
t-minus two minutes yep already forgot
sorry no amount of alcohol or being
drunk is gonna make you go oh that
movies still fun all right spoiler alert
what I hated about the ending does the
fact Halle Berry goes to this place she
suspects the guys holding Abigail
Breslin and she finds his little
trapdoor goes down there and says hold
they try to be like Silence of the Lambs
but it made sense for Silence of the
Lambs because Clarice was an FBI agent
and this chick is a 911 dispatcher but
she knocks a dude out gets abigail
breslin she's like wait don't call the
cops and he tied the guy up in a chair
he wakes up and he's like alright one of
the cops coming they're like the cops
oh no and it's one of these girl power
moments was like man we took matters
into our own hands and now you're gonna
rot down here and die and the story they
come up with is well Abigail got found
in the woods somewhere by the 900s
patcher because the teenage girl escaped
the place and then you know that's that
and the implication is the guy is going
to remain chained in this underground
basement place it's pretty hidden and
he's gonna starve to death and die
couple problems first of all that is
implying that teenage girls are good
Liars women are not good Liars let alone
teenage girls she's gonna be like oh I
escaped the cops gonna be like from work
she's gonna be like I don't remember but
they're gonna be like yeah [ __ ]
where'd you escape from and why were you
911 dispatcher the one who found her why
did you not call 9-1-1 why did you not
call the cops when you suspected you
knew where she was after they get caught
in their web of lies Halle Berry's
probably gonna get in trouble you can
pass it off is probably gonna be a slap
on the wrist when the girls like oh you
found me in these woods over here no
like all right we need to search a
radius of two miles let's find where she
was and they do find the little basement
may go down there and the guy's chained
up in a chair they're gonna be like huh
hey 911 dispatcher did you chain him up
and leave him to die yeah you're going
to jail now I mean I'm down for the
whole revenge thing if you want to kill
the guy cool but just make sure you can
get away with it you're not gonna get
away with it and don't bring the teenage
girl in on your dark revenge scheme and
that is implying the guy actually stays
chained up in the chair if the guy gets
out of those chains I'm pretty sure he
knows how to get out of his own little
trapdoor basement so he's gonna get away
you just let the killer
away because you wanted to be cool and
well now he got away I'm telling you it
just it didn't make sense Dexter Morgan
to be like that's a sloppy as it gets
that's tonight Dexter music always helps
when I talk about [ __ ] ending so yeah
the movies not great and then the ending
is just terrible so your favorite
kidnapping movie of all time don't count
out firing this guy cuz it technically
is one what's your favorite whatever it
is comment below let me know favorite
kidnapping movie might be a little
sounds a little weird to say but I guess
it says genre and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more